speaking of young controversial men i
meant to get to this last week but i'll
get to it now
madison cawthorne madison cawthorne is a
freshman member of congress young guy
young conservative member of congress
and boy has he been in the headlines
lately boy has madison catherine been in
the headlines oh man it seems like this
guy can't do anything right he uh
just about two weeks ago there were big
headlines about how
madison cawthorne might be guilty of
financial impropriety or insider trading
because he invested in a in a crypto
coin and then there was another headline
madison cawthorne was caught driving
with a a license revoked because he had
had some speeding tickets that he hadn't
paid yet and then last week this was a
really weird one there was this video
that leaked
with madison cawthorne it looked like he
was
not wearing very much clothing and he
was kind of like he was i don't know he
was like doing something on a couch with
a buddy of his or something they were
kind of he was like yelling and i don't
know i don't know i didn't didn't watch
it all that closely
and and uh but people were saying this
is really weird this is a shocking
scandalous video and
i thought huh
why
why is everyone going after madison
cawthorne right now
because none of these none of these
scandals in particular seem all that
just it's not like there was an actual
sex tape of him that leaked it's not
like he was caught committing some crime
on camera or something it was like kind
of a strange video but i know there are
lots of strange videos
and then
driving while his license was revoked
that's is that the when i think of the
crimes that members of congress
regularly commit that seems pretty low
on the list and then he invested in some
in some stupid crypto coin that that's
what why are they go oh i i remember why
they're going after him because madison
cauter and blow the whistle on their on
their coke fueled orgies just a few
weeks ago
the sexual perversion that goes on
washing i mean it being kind of a young
guy in washington with the average age
of probably 60 or 70.
and i look at all these people a lot of
them that i you know i've looked up to
through my life i've always paid
attention to politics guys that you know
then all of a sudden you get invited to
like well hey we're going to have kind
of a
sexual get-together at one of our homes
you should come and i'm like
what did you just ask me to come to yeah
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an orgy yeah uh or the fact
that you know there's some of the people
that are leading on the movement to try
and remove you know addiction in our
country and then you watch them do you
know a key bump of cocaine right in
front of you and it's like wow this is
this is wild
when madison catherine made these claims
i was not totally sure that he was
telling the truth or that these things
were actually happening i thought it was
likely that what he was saying was true
but i wasn't totally sure
now that
pretty much the moment he made those
comments on air
now that
every single day it seems there is a new
negative headline there is a new hit
piece against him i am now 100 certain
that what he was saying
was true
and look we we know that washington dc
is extremely corrupt we know that
members of our government are very
frequently degenerate and we know that
they've all got blackmail on one another
okay that has been true for
at least the blackmail part has been
true for the entire history of politics
but what clawthrone here is describing
is now actually happening because in
that interview he says look and the way
that everyone covers it up is everyone
says look you shouldn't say this thing
you shouldn't vote this way you
shouldn't do this thing because we've
got some videotape of you or we've got
some arrest record of you or we've got
some bads that would sure look bad in
the headlines and they're all
using this dirt to control one another
this is the this is the plot line of the
of house of cards this is you see this
throughout lbj's life and that robert
carobiography of lbj in particular
you wielded blackmail and so i totally
buy it madison catherine when he made
these claims
the republican leadership too we got
really angry with him
oh boy did they come down hard on him
and he sort of recanted it a little bit
but not totally and they're obviously
just pressuring him and now they're
trying to send a message
um this is another example of i think
the tactics are backfiring here
okay i think the tactic of sending angry
mobs to the conservative justices homes
they thought that that was going to give
them the outcome they wanted i think
really it's just i hope it's hardening
the justices on this and it's certainly
hardening the american people you can
see even just since the leak came out
you can see momentum moving in the
pro-life direction same thing here if i
was 50 50 on madison cothren talking
about the coke-fueled orgies in
washington dc i'm now more like 80 20.
i'm now more like 90 10 here i'm now
pretty certain that what he's saying is
true because the the intimidation
campaign against him is so blatant
i refer to myself occasionally as
nostradamus well look at what catherine
did talk about a crystal ball he said
look they're going to start leaking a
bunch of stuff about me if if i talk
about their coke-fueled orgies and then
what do you get two weeks later
i'm glad you like that clip now ding
ding ding ring that bell subscribe get
all the notifications smash that button
whatever you know just leave a comment
or whatever and also check out the
michael knowles show at apple podcast
spotify stitcher google wherever you get
your audio podcasts we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you